a Walmart store is being slammed after a
picture went viral of a back-to-school
gun display they had a big own the
school year like a hero display above a
variety of firearms as part of their
August back-to-school messaging Walmart
has since apologized they said they're
trying to figure out where did this
happen who put this up they responded by
saying that it was truly awful and
horrible and spokesman Charles Kraus and
said to CNN money that the company is
not happy with this and they're working
diligently to find out where the photo
was taken and make sure that the sign is
removed Walmart had another controversy
recently when a Panama City Florida
Walmart put up stacked boxes of
coca-cola uh I guess you would call them
cases to resemble the World Trade Center
in some kind of effort I guess to
commemorate 9/11 back in September
Walmart corporate said we did not mean
any disrespect and they quickly took it
down and then of course back in 2014
Walmart had to apologize for selling
quote fat girl costumes on its Web site
who thought that was a good idea and
they've also had a bunch of Nazi and
racist memorabilia and posters sold on
their web sites before but they've said
those were third party products sort of
like you can find products on Amazon
that aren't sold by Amazon same sort of
idea with Walmart's website but it still
doesn't look particularly good I don't
know if this is the biggest of deals
though because yes we can go after
Walmart for selling guns or maybe being
too large of a corporation but we all
know that mistakes are going to happen
in retail every now and then and
sometimes there's a bit of irony
involved or I guess incentives it's
insensitivity in this case but as long
as they apologize for the negligence is
it really that big of a deal well I
don't go to Walmart I haven't been there
in more than a decade but having worked
in retail before I've told stories about
my exploits at the now-defunct Circuit
City to me this is pretty clearly the
doing of a particular employee usually
the waving or deliberate what's that you
think this was deliberately done well it
was deliberately done by some employee
now whether they did it to create
controversy or because they thought that
the guns were part of the back-to-school
specials I don't know but and most of
these retailers corporate sends to the
stores these packages with signs and
these diagrams that are usually very
difficult to read and explain sort of
like where do you put each thing and
management
at them they usually just give them to
somebody who's making who knows how many
few dollars per hour and they say yeah
put this display together so I I think
it's pretty clear that this is no
corporate policy of Walmart to market
guns is back to school it's either a
joke from an individual employee or just
a mistake from an innocent employee if
it's a mistake that's one thing I don't
think it's that big of a deal if there
was some intent behind it and that
employee went rogue and thought this
would be funny that's a whole nother
deal I would be hard to prove hard to
prove intent for sure you know who's
curious though about this this apology
Education Secretary Betsy DeVos how were
schools going to protect themselves from
grizzly bears if Walmart doesn't offer
back to school school gun discounts or
even just potential Grizzlies they write
the which is really the only actual
concern if Walmart really wants to
apologize there's a lot that Walmart
should be apologizing for right Walmart
should apologize for claiming to be this
great self-sufficient business and the
beacon of capitalism and bootstrapping
and whatever when they actually depend
on government welfare programs to
subsidize the low salaries they pay
their employees everything from food
stamps to Medicaid while right-wingers
point to Walmart as this free market big
business success and it's not just
Walmart that that criticism is valid for
we've talked about it with McDonald's
all these companies that talk about
their amazing business acumen and how
they don't depend on everyone they built
this great business they've built those
businesses on the Commons with employee
benefits heavily subsidized by
government welfare and we've seen
Walmart had these end-of-the-year
donations rally yeah or benefits for
their own employee right I mean how
bizarre is that maybe they're offered
free guns as well I doubt it I doubt
that but that would be that would be
interesting do you shop at Walmart ever
I I've completely stranded off Walmart
years ago and I know that for a while
there there were sort of rumblings that
target is just as bad as Walmart for
that type of store I've done enough
research where I I'm generally confident
saying Target is not as bad as Walmart
if you're going to be going to one of
those stores and I get it sometimes it's
you know 9:30 at night and you need X
immediately and it's either Walmart or
Target and while you might want to go to
some local business you're not able to
I do believe Target is better than wall
especially if you live in a rural area
in the middle of the country and Walmart
is the reason for a lot of those local
businesses yes shutting down to begin
with you know what I've been hearing
about I know that some people that I
sound so out of touch when I say this
but it's very different in cities than
it is in some parts of the country I've
heard that in some parts of the country
the the one grocery store is walmart
walmart has grocery items I don't know
if in all stores or just some stores at
this point I think it's just some I know
they have pantry items in most stores
but as far as the character delivery
yeah and people are going to to Walmart
for groceries and Target also has I was
recently at the Target in Hadley
Massachusetts and you can get fruit
there you can get I don't know what else
I don't know yeah so anyway sad I find I
don't know why I find it depressing like
you could say hey Walmart's one of the
biggest purveyors of organic foods in
the country by volume that's probably
true but I still find it depressing and
I don't know exactly why you don't got
to do it someone's got to do it I guess
and that's who is pushing out a lot of
small businesses in more rural parts of
the country